on today's episode which is the same
backward as it is forward we are joined
by the big boss himself the Slayer of
leftist arguments the repository of data
the fire of Piers Morgan the one and
only Ben Shapiro then roaming millennial
Jacob Erie and Amanda presto Giacomo
joined the panel of deplorable z-- to
discuss Hillary's latest buck stops
everywhere but here finger-pointing
Facebook's claiming to have more data
than the US Census and the latest
minority in America white Christians
can't wait for my affirmative action I
am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
there is plenty that we could talk about
today there's so much news
there's the daca stuff there's always
the latest Trump shenanigans and I don't
want to talk about any of it because we
are joined in studio by them in in the
broom closet of the ben shapiro show by
the one and only Ben Shapiro god help us
man I want to go back to the very
beginning I want to go all the way
through I want everything that you've
always wanted to know about ben shapiro
but we're too afraid to ask and so to
start at the very beginning i think we
need to begin with this clip it is in
gentlemen benjamin Shapiro
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's I'm sorry it's just so beautiful
[ __ ]
yeah for those who weren't watching that
would be what six or seven year old Ben
Shapiro now if I was a little man that
was I was like 11 or 12 that was there's
an 11 or 12 year old Ben Shapiro
playing violin playing Fiddler on the
Roof over sobbing Democrat sobbing
Democrats really beautiful stuff really
hard thank you so in there you're as
little as you can be mm-hmm you've
always been a conservative you popped
out of the womb of conservative yes I
was never a neocon right it's inferred
I'm Jewish but it's a bet aside from New
York I just means truth and that that's
what I thought as well but it turns out
not so I was I was never on the left I
was always very conservative I mean I
had my syndicated column on conservative
politics when I was 17 I started UCLA
when I was 16 and the first thing that I
thought I was gonna major in biology and
music because of that and then I walked
in tears to say good combination and
then I saw a newspaper on campus I
opened it up there was an editorial
comparing Arielle cherone the Prime
Minister of Israel to 805 home in the
Nazi so I walked into the office of the
daily Bruin and I said I'd like to write
a piece rebutting that and they said
sure and so that turned into me doing a
point-counterpoint column and then a
regular column and then I sort of
applied cold to create her syndicate
which syndicated at the time like Molly
Ivins on the left and David Limbaugh on
Michelle Malkin on the right and they
called me back like three weeks later
and said they wanted to do a weekly
column with me they didn't actually know
how old I was so they were surprised my
parents had to sign the contract because
I was underage so that was cool so what
is you come out of the womb juh playing
for Larry King and making lemons cry
what you're the primary influences on
your politics obvious I know your family
yeah they're not a lot of Democrats
there that's right yeah is it some is it
all most of the family is that though is
it reading you did is it just a
disposition that
you have so I do think that there's
there is something dispositional I mean
I'm by nature a pessimist but I but I
think that you know my parents obviously
played a very heavy role in my politics
particularly social politics but as far
as you know economics that's just
reading
that's that self education a foreign
policy I was always very hawkish but I
think it really is that I have a very
moralistic streak and it's very
difficult to be a lefty and have a
strong moralistic streak a belief in
personal responsibility well you have
sort of deep beliefs that's sort of the
root of my entire philosophy rests on
personal accountability and
responsibility very difficult to be a
member of the left and believe that that
is the core of your goal is to be
personally responsible for your own
conduct and you bring up a key phrase
which is self teaching yeah because
presumably you're not reading Hayek in
high school or any of these other
thinkers right who are the same thing
for me same thing for most conservatives
I know
mmm cuz we got reading lists outside of
regular curriculum who are the readers
that most are the writer's rather who
most effected your thinking so on
economics the the number one book I
always recommend and it's great for high
school students is Henry Hazlitt
economics in one lesson that's right
it's just a beautifully short reads like
170 pages and very well-written and very
clear and then so on economics and then
so on on issues of general cosmic
significance I mean the quest for cosmic
justice is an excellent book so soul is
thinking I think later Hayek and some
more sophisticated you know writers but
those were those are the earliest
iterations and but it depends topic by
topic so so those are mostly economic
all those soul writes about everything
right exactly
what about on political philosophy writ
large you know the Russell Kirk Edmund
Burke that oh yes I'm actually not a
huge Russell Kirk fan believe it or not
I think conservative mind is more
dispositional than it is than it is
positional meaning that it is it's more
about your disposition toward politics
and you sort of want to keep things
where they are as opposed to change its
very Berkey and I mean obviously
critical bases work on Burke I mostly
cuz they rhymed exactly a few people
know that I'm less I'm less a Burkean
guy than I am a revolutionary theorist
guy so Burke Burke is much more of a
conservative case against the French
Revolution
and I'm much more in line with sort of
locking in political philosophy and
Burke was sort of lukewarm on that as
well as opposed to being a thoroughgoing
Lockean that is interesting there was
this book by Yuval Levin comparing Burke
and Payne mm-hmm and the answer for any
American conservative is you have a
little bit of both right exactly Locke
is sort of halfway in between those two
and and that's where the founders I
think lived I think it's where they
spend most of their time with Locke and
Montesquieu and Burke was a little bit
later and Paine was considered radical
by most of the founders so that's yeah
in terms of political philosophy that's
where I started and you know if you want
to show your kids a movie that will
actually get you in that mode then watch
1776 great great movie about founding
philosophy where they actually discuss
these sorts of ideas and enshrine them
so so you're you're young you know what
you think you're super smart at this
young age you're playing for Larry King
you're doing all these things how do you
survive in on two levels one just
interpersonally you're clearly ahead of
your classmates let's say and and then
in this culture in a culture that
perhaps does not encourage the sort of
thinking that you have and the sort of
activities that you pursue and the
religiosity that you have so I think
that there are a few things that that
play into that the first is that I had
to grow a thick skin pretty young
because being Orthodox being a lot
smaller than everybody cuz I was a lot
younger and smaller than everybody and
and I wasn't I was in and out of public
school so I wasn't like I went to
private school my entire life I spent
all the way through fourth grade in
public school in seventh in seventh and
eighth grade I was in public school and
then I was in private school for high
school but when I was in seventh and
eighth grade particularly that was time
when my parents it already became
Orthodox and we were already Orthodox
and I was a lot shorter than everybody
else were you always worth it oh no my
parents became fully Orthodox when I was
like eleven
so I remember eating at KFC oh and yeah
that mutt that's the thorn in your side
that st. Paul would write about that the
kosher eating is is difficult I mean I
can't tell you how many great
restaurants have gone to just looked at
the food it happens all the time now and
like I went to dinner at somebody's
house the other night and this is a very
very wealthy person they had their own
chef in their house and I said well I
can't eat any R food we're gonna pick up
dinner beforehand so they're eating like
this um filet mignon and I bought like a
burger from the
Koecher standing on a paper plate and
there at their house there's some of
that but you know it i was i was shorter
than everybody in middle school which
some of them said that hasn't changed
and that has twitter twitter what do you
think that's exactly are sitting down
we're not gonna stand up four foot three
and and so that started i was bullied a
little bit in public school I was
actually relentlessly bullied in high
school cuz I'd skipped two grades so I
was I was now much younger than all the
other kids and so I was brutally bullied
in high school and you can react one of
two ways you can sort of crawl in your
show or you can basically say f you
exactly and grow a thick skin and so I
think it was actually a good testing
ground for growing a thick skin because
in this business you better have a thick
skin and so by the time I got to college
this was cake I mean I was treated
better in college than I was in high
school you know like I was I was
regularly physically abused in high
school so so once you got to college
it's like wow Brees leaving me alone we
can actually talk about things much less
frequently when you're in a university
setting
not without occasion yeah woman now I'd
not risk it more than I did when I was
in college but yeah that's exactly right
now it's interesting to bring up the
religiosity the conversion to Orthodoxy
for your family because I think there's
a prevailing ethos that religious people
are a little stupider or naive or
unthoughtful or intentionally
unthoughtful in my own experience I find
people who are not educated or
necessarily intelligent can be quite
religious mm-hm and I found that people
who are extraordinarily intelligent or
educated can be quite religious and
often are and then there's this middle
ground of total atheism yeah I think
that's right I think the reason that's
right is because a lot of people who are
hardcore atheist I'm not talking about
agnostics cuz I think the only
evidence-based position on God is
agnosticism sure
because there's no other evidence of
anything like you can go either way but
as far as kind of hardcore atheists a
lot of atheists or very hardcore and
very vocal about they seem to think
they're the first people who ever
figured out that like a virgin birth is
kind of unlikely or that God speaking
from a mountaintop is kind of weird like
there's people just ever occurred to in
the history of humanity like it's
brand-new no one's ever thought of this
or though they'll talk about the problem
of theodicy and they'll both sit around
going well you know I had a friend who
cancer when they were young how could a
good God allow this and now but you know
religious thinkers never talked about
that it's like there's 2500 years of
religious thought on exactly this top it
is incredible that people will bring up
this question as a as a trump card right
you'll say well why would a good god let
bad things happen and you think you're
not asking me that you could google it
and you would you would get eternal
books about right and they may not
satisfy you but the I did there's no
sort of explanation for that that any
religious person is never thought like
they expect me to convert on the spot
you're right now I'm an atheist because
you drop that on me no I mean most
religious people have doubts most
religious people understand there's a
difference between faith and knowledge
that's why it's called faith that's why
it's called belief you're a believer
right you're not a knower you're a
believer and there's a clip of me saying
that I know in God but and saying no God
right I said I know in God because no
human being is capable of knowing God I
know the place of humanity in the world
because I believe there is a God but I
think that that is a different standard
than religious person who never even
thinks about whether God exists or what
God wants from us I think that in its
written right into the Bible I mean I
think that the key moment in in biblical
history they're they're a bunch of them
that people sort of point out in the Old
Testament anyway the key moment for
Christians very easy but for Jews
there's just one I guess - there's the
birth and the and the death and
resurrection right that's very simple it
really boils down in the sequel and the
sequel they really boil it down but in
the but in the original the there are a
few different there are a few different
sort of points that people use in as
inflection points sacrifice of Isaac the
the exodus from Egypt but I think the
real key moment is a quieter moment
because this is the moment when Israel
is actually founded and that is the
wrestling match between Jacob and the
angel right that's when Jacob's name is
switched to Israel that's the first time
that Israel is used in the Bible as the
Internet becomes the foundation of all
of religion and yesterday L literally
means struggle with God right it says
right in the in the in the clinician
sits right there in the Bible that this
means and you struggled with God and
overcame that's what religious people do
every day we struggle with the goodness
of God the presence of God the imminence
of God we struggle with that all times
you're not struggling you're not
thinking about it and God wants you to
struggle with that because if you're
struggling with it then it means there's
a baseline level of belief you don't
struggle with things that you think are
imaginary don't struggle with Santa
Claus or the Easter Bunny he's your wife
you struggle with your family
right people that you love that you have
a relationship exactly mm-hmm
do you think because all the time we
hear especially from Young Conservatives
well I'm fiscally conservative but
socially liberal well I'm I just want to
focus on policy that works and there
there seems to be a metaphysical
ignorance or a neglect of metaphysics
I agree do you think that there needs to
be a metaphysical basis for conservatism
I think that if you want to think it
through for more than five minutes yes
because I think that you can live in the
political world and not really think
about the basis of your thought but I
mean it's it's it's fascinating always
when you talk to people who aren't
religious or who disparaged the
judeo-christian tradition upon which
this entire culture was built and
they'll they'll use judeo-christian
terms right they'll use judeo-christian
definitions of good and evil but use
judeo-christian notions of Rights that
don't exist in the absence of
judeo-christian culture right they don't
exist anywhere else on planet earth for
all time and then you know the idea that
you haven't really thought these things
through it's dangerous I mean every
every political philosophy is based on a
certain conception of human nature and
human humanity's place in the world and
human value more than anything else I
mean the foundational statement for all
of Western civilization is the very
beginning of Genesis that God has made
in man that man has made in God's image
but once you do that you can talk about
the value of man the rights of man what
what is man put here to do but if you
don't believe any of that if you just
believe the man is sort of a random
assemblage of atoms that happened along
you know because the universe is random
there are lots of iterations of it then
I find a hard time making the moral
argument against for example things like
slavery or abortion or tyranny or murder
even I mean like were capital punishment
on the flips capital I mean if you are
basically just in and unless you're
janus and you believe all forms of life
should equally be protected but that's a
religion too if you believe like a
secular version of that and then okay I
guess I buy it but otherwise you have to
explain what makes human being special
and why is that special most worthy of
protection it does lead to this what it
seems to me disingenuous determinism
that seems to be the logical conclusion
of that material is thinking and
disingenuous is the right word because I
think that one ends up happening it's
very weird is when you talk to a lot of
people who are atheists like I read sam
Harris's books and I've met Sam and I
think Sam's a smart guy and I
when I when I read what Sam has to say a
lot of what he has to say is based on
just an assumption of free will there's
an assumption that you can choose
otherwise that you were in control of
your own life and that you should live a
moral life that he has constructed for
you his version of what morality looks
like Alan Dershowitz sort of has a
similar model and the problem is where
are you getting this free will stuff in
a materialistic universe in which you're
just a random assemblage of atoms like
where is this freewill coming from where
do you get that and how do you square
that with a materialist version of
reality you know I think that the best
proof of God I've always said this I
think the best proof of God to me is our
own is sort of a Cartesian notion that
you are a thinker you are a being I can
get Hansel it's myself right you are a
self right you're not just a random
assemblage of stuff that wakes up new
every morning and that if you have a
hamburger you're a different person than
you are one minute before because you
just put some new stuff in your body
right this is the notion that you are a
coherent human being with the capacity
to think and the capacity to control
your behavior and the capacity to change
that's the basis of all of civilization
take away that basic Augustinian notion
of free will and it's all over I
couldn't agree more
so you've read all the books you've read
sanika and stamina decart and all these
people most people haven't read all the
books if you're a young conservative
either you're on campus here in high
school or something you want to join the
vast right-wing conspiracy you want to
get your card I keep mine on my wallet
all the time what should you do what
should you and I don't just mean what
books you should read honestly you
should do that too but what what should
they would be young conservative be
doing right now well I mean I think the
first thing you should do is work hard I
think working hard is basically the
first notion in in any conservative
philosophy if you are willing to work
hard for your own betterment then you're
already moving in the right direction
politically because you're an individual
who feels you need to better yourself
you're not just a piece of garbage in a
collection so if you value yourself
enough to work hard then I think that
you're gonna move in a conservative
direction sort of automatically I think
that you know in terms of reading
obviously you should read the same text
that were good enough for Lincoln I mean
if you read the Bible and Shakespeare
and follow that up with the Federalist
Papers I think you start with those
three and and you'll be in pretty good
shape a route respect for Western
civilization lies at the core of
conservative philosophy which is why we
wear
we want to conserve and something left
wants to tear down so if you have a
respect for these institutions of
Western civilization and you say yes
they were flawed and yes it's our goal
to perfect them and make sure that the
original aspirations are fulfilled
generation / generation improved over
time then we can make
purrr what we were given but that's not
quite the same thing as what the left is
saying which is that what we were given
is garbage and if we just discard that
we can build something brand-new and
just wait till I get my hands on and I'm
gonna do great yeah exactly the last
couple centuries is as someone said to
me on Sunday night the last couple
centuries have been very poor proof of
the idea that secular humanism has a
great record in remaking man in a
positive direction like that that
argument would have swung a lot better
than that in 1788 right before the
Revolution looks a lot better mm-hmm we
have to talk a little bit about politics
I thought I get to the lightning round
the Ben Shapiro lightning round which is
what I'm most excited for only someone
of been Shapiro's linguistic speed and
and thoughtful speed could answer all 25
questions this quickly but before we get
to that before we get to that we I'm
frustrated at all these daca headlines
yeah because I think a lot of people are
missing the point some of the
politicians making decisions about this
are missing the point the implication I
think from the left is that any decision
to reduce either legal or illegal
immigration is racist certainly to
reduce legal immigration when we hear
the alt-right guys making fairly racist
points themselves on this topic what is
the non racist argument to reduce legal
immigration so the non racist argument
is less about reduction than who's
coming in the country so I don't think
that so there's an economic argument
that some people make they suggest that
we would raise American wages if we
limited the amount of Labor I'm not a
big fan of that argument because it's
basically the same argument as minimum
wage right if you want to limit the
number of the amount of labor all you
have to do is create a legislative
create a bill that that limits the
amount of Labor you'll raise the wage
but you'll put a lot of people out of
work and you'll destroy the base of the
economy but it's but other than that is
great but the the legal immigrant
restrictive argument is we have a
culture worth preserving its
judeo-christian culture you have to be
prepared to assimilate into that call
to even be looked at and we as a society
have no necessary responsibility to take
in everybody who wants to get in unless
they also service that civilization
unless they are willing to be
participants in that civilization have
demonstrated evidence that they're
willing to be participants in that
civilization that's the that's the
principled argument and that it's the
it's the argument the alt-right
constantly gets wrong they equate they
say it's about race and it's not about
race it's always about culture they quit
racing culture they're not the same
thing at all I mean of course they're a
bunch of they're a bunch of savages
running around Britain before before
Julius Caesar invaded well they were
exactly the same
I think sherry hundred years ago right
exactly it's it's it's quite ridiculous
actually to suggest that race is the
fundamental precursor to civilization
when again Italians were being
discriminated against when they came to
the United States in the 19th century
I'm pretty swarthy swarthy guy I don't
know that I meet their criteria and yet
a lot of the people who presumably would
have been quote-unquote alright in the
19th century Andres criminate against
Italians we're talking about the glories
of Roman civilization so it's really not
about race not real cognitive dissonance
oK we've got to get to this lightning
round I bet we can do it in like two
minutes really okay here are the
dichotomies just the first thing that
comes to your mind with the superhuman
Shapiro's speed favorite novel so I'll
go with I have like four or five of them
actually so mo moby-dick is my favorite
if I have to pick one take to a desert
island is Moby Dick alright best
American novel then they're a bunch that
nobody's ever heard of there's one club
every man dies alone which is a terrific
book about a couple who are living in
Nazi Germany and they decide to
basically put out leaflets their son has
been killed in the war the Germans their
sons been killed in the war as a brown
shirt and they have decided to put out
leaflets resisting Hitler knowing it's
not really gonna do any good about their
relationship it's a terrific book by a
guy named Hans falada who's writing at
the time in Germany so that that's a
really good book there's a little
another little known book that's really
enjoyable just a fun book is called the
secret of Santa Vittorio by Robert
Crichton they made a movie out of it
that I don't think is particularly good
but the book itself is a really great
read and then of course you have to add
some of the Russians write good crime
and punishment Anna Karenina but yeah
those would be at Southwest all right
favorite philosopher so I would say
either console or lock which is a real
dichotomy its yeah
smash them both together and try to make
sense of that I suppose but but it's
hard it's hard to root against canta
canta it's pretty fun spectacular
although reading Conte is brutal just
read a summary of comment you'll be
better off it is awful it took me so
long and so much masochism to get
through the critique of pure reason it's
in you could literally just have
somebody summarize it for you and get as
much out of it as try and slide your way
through 800 pages of badly translated
your favorite color uh yellow Athens or
Jerusalem I mean that's that both I mean
Lepanto or tours neither LA or DC la la
la Ponte la Batman or Superman oh that's
hard that's the hardest one you've given
me versus Superman if Batman killed
people Batman perfect favorite musical
the one that's closest to my heart is
1776 the one that's the most brilliant
to Sweeney Todd favorite movie again I
would have to go like top 10 but the
Lord of the Rings trilogy is fantastic
the Dark Knight trilogy is fantastic
there's a man for all seasons used to be
my favorite for a long time the what's
the name of the film now they made a
remake all the king's men with the
original with Broderick Crawford was up
there on my list Truman shows a great
movie I have a list of I'll have to do
my own list of top hundred movies I've
seen every oscar-nominated film since
1933
so of course you personally all of them
anyway yeah spirit animal spirit animal
God my spirit animals Ben Shapiro
actually what is your what has been
Shapiro spirit animal I don't even like
animals edmund spenser
well Richard Spencer anyone who's not
Richard yeah among whom is edmund
spenser a good poet democracy or
meritocracy meritocracy meritocracy or
monarchy meritocracy
Yale or Harvard I went to Harvard Law
School did Yale erotic stream yeah oh
that's pretty good I thought I was gonna
have to go down like ten of those before
and I'll take it my country right or
wrong my country when it's right my
country when it's right
regular coke or Diet Coke of regular
coke Edmund Burke or Thomas Paine you
have to pick one
Edmund Burke greatest composer Beethoven
favorite book of the Bible that's
another hard one although our Canon is a
lot smaller than yours it's I do have a
particularly love for Samuel wanted to
the all the David and install stuff is
dead has to note to self read Samuel one
and two uh Lord of the Rings we're game
with runs uh Lord of the Rings a hot dog
is a sandwich a hot dog is not a simple
hot dog is not a sandwich you have to
have two separate pieces of bread
magazine what about a hoagie a hoagie
doesn't have two separate pieces of
bread also not a sandwich well my guys
is outrageous a final question the right
to bear arms the right to arm bears what
does freedom mean to you well I mean
what kind of country would we be if we
couldn't do both this is a great point
everybody
Ben Shapiro Ben thank you for coming on
so I a real pleasure thank you for
everything it's been mediocre it's been
just solidly media edited out Marshall
Ben thank you for coming now we have to
move to the panel of deplorable so we
have to bring them on roaming millennial
Amanda presto Giacomo and Jacob arey all
right guys we're not gonna comment on
anything like that how are you gonna
beat Ben Shapiro
he just ran through all of the important
questions in the world so we have to
move straight down to news and before we
get to that we have to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube I know you haven't
even heard from the panel today well
tough guys you have to go to daily
wired.com right now and pay either $10 a
month or $100 a year
to subscribe you'll get my show you'll
get the Andrew Clavin show you'll get
the bench Pierrot show one of the
biggest podcasts in the whole country
and forget all that you'll get the
leftist here's tumblr the leftist here's
tumblr is so it is the finest vehicle
for not only leftist ears but any
beverage in the whole country you can
have them hot or cold always salty and
delicious go over there right now daily
wire calm and we will be right back
[Music]
it was my campaign
those were my decisions that's Hillary
Clinton giving her latest excuses in
interviews about her new book she says I
think it's fair to say that I didn't
trickle I realize how quickly the ground
was shifting under an all our feet I was
running a traditional presidential
campaign with carefully thought-out
policies and painstakingly built
coalition's while Trump was running a
reality TV show that expertly and
relentlessly stoked Americans anger and
resentment what makes me such a good
lightning rod for fury I'm really asking
I'm at a loss I think it's particularly
or rather it's partly because I'm a
woman that was Hillary Clinton accepting
responsibility for her loss a man to
help her out
what makes Hillary such a lightning rod
for fury Hillary she's one of the worst
candidates I've ever seen she couldn't
campaign your way out of a paper bag
but but it's just so funny that she has
this it's kind of like a leftist
mentality where she blames everybody
else but herself
I actually I think it was in January I
composed a list of everything Hillary's
blamed so it's basically her book what
happened but in list form and it was I
think we were like honestly like at
least like 35 different entities or
people she blamed you know Bernie
Sanders Comey
sexism the right-wing conspiracy
WikiLeaks Russia of the DNC Netflix
that's one of my favorites she was too
truthful white women I mean there is no
real reflection on Hillary anytime
there's criticism it's it's somebody
else's fault something doesn't go her
way it's somebody else's fault we saw
this in the 90s as well there's you know
it's everyone else to blame not Hillary
you're absolutely right that does
characterize the Clintons and
particularly Hillary just only passing
the buck
but roaming does she have any point did
her being a woman play into her loss at
all in any way I'm trying her not trying
to give Hillary a fair shake only
because she's my second cousin once
removed well you know what I'm not gonna
say that her being woman didn't stop
anyone from voting for her right I mean
they're sexist everywhere I'm sure there
are at least
people out there who thought you know
what a woman not for me but the question
is was it an institutional part of her
losing right was it something that
actually had an impact on the election
you know in a larger sense and I've got
to say no when we look at the breakdown
of demographics we see okay well across
women won them all obviously women
aren't gonna be scared of voting for a
woman and you know what even across you
know male demographics when it comes to
the Hispanic vote the black vote it just
unless you're specifically accusing
white males of being sexist than no it
just doesn't make sense and I mean if
you look at the campaign she ran you'd
have to be I guess willfully ignorant to
say that's probably just because I'm a
woman okay it is it's willful ignorance
and wishful thinking I think on her part
Jacob is she seriously confused as to
why she lost
is she really at such a loss and
wondering about this or is she just
faking it to get sympathy I think she is
confused but for a different reason I
think that her supporters that I should
say her inner circle they're telling her
you lost because of Bernie Sanders you
lost because of Barack Obama when I was
at Politico and I I went to a panel
where Paul Begala was speaking and he
was he was just regurgitating everything
that Hillary Clinton has saying so I
honestly think that it's her inner
circle telling it's not you it's them
it's got nothing to do with you so I
think that is confusing her and it's
forcing her to or should say if she's
more than happy to go along with it cuz
otherwise it's like Amanda says she's a
terrible candidate which she is and if
Paul Begala says it it's obviously a
coordinated response because those
Clintons are always scheming for
something facebook is claiming that it's
advertising now reaches more people than
the US Census say live in the country a
for comment we have to turn to Mark
Zuckerberg
[Music]
careful of what you say be careful in
every way be careful of what you do big
brother is watching you he has a lower
voice than I thought he would I was
actually surprised when I heard that
take roaming does this show a weakness
in techie tyranny or is Facebook more
correct than the US Census you know what
government or Facebook
neither groups where I'm kind of
throwing my trust at them yes let me
take your information at your word this
is a hard one but you know what I've got
to go with the US Census and I think
it's not like we can't imagine reason
why Facebook would want to inflate its
numbers or it's not like we can imagine
that you know what maybe this isn't
malicious maybe they just are honestly
having tech issues where they're reading
things wrong either way I am NOT taking
this seriously I don't think they're
right and I think it's interesting
because you know there's been so much
hype over Zuckerberg possibly running at
least you know in certain corners of the
internet and a cilantro slate right so
it's this is an interesting thing
because if I look at you know anything
that's critical of Facebook or
Zuckerberg at all it's not really being
reported as much by those saying I guess
mainstream media outlets so I you know
yeah I would like to say that this is
something that yeah it's great let's
look at Facebook's policy is a little
bit more let's look at you know some of
the things they're selling to
advertisers maybe a little bit critical
but I don't think most people will care
about this roaming you bring up a great
incentive that Zuckerberg would have to
inflate his influence which is that he
appears to want to run for president and
he gives us those super cringy photos of
him at Iowa lunch counters which are
really wonderful they're the best thing
on the Internet in the last year
probably but Amanda is Facebook
intentionally inflating its numbers
either to milk advertisers or to promote
Mark Zuckerberg for president or are
they just having a glitch or they just
not as all-powerful as we thought they
were like roaming said you can imagine
why they would want to you know again
for for advertise
and such it wouldn't make sense why they
wouldn't plate those numbers and also I
do think there are a lot of people this
might seem simplistic but I feel like
there are a ton of people have multiple
accounts like you know and they said
they know in the Wall Street Journal
they've been saying that I was like one
of the factors that they're just like
multiple accounts for a lot of people so
like things like that I think can
actually contribute but but yeah I mean
Facebook is super powerful and Macroom
instead I mean between a choice of you
know believing the US government and
Facebook it's like it's basically it's
awesome they both have so much power
difficult for news companies to
criticize Mark Zuckerberg or Facebook
because they do somebody all the news so
it is kind of hard to tackle that I
think there are a lot of news companies
who are kind of like you know kind of go
a little easy on this because they do
kind of control everything and there
have been instances where people have
accused the the organization of
basically having bias you know we've
seen that multiple times so again it's
like he's not open to criticism - so
that's that's also a little dangerous it
is Occam's razor also I hadn't even
considered that but everybody has
multiple accounts I've had several four
different political things I've been up
to and so that very well might explain
my ex-boyfriends no Jacob will there
ever come a time when tech giants are a
threat to the Republic when they have
more information than the government
when they have more power than the
government or we there now and what what
is the implication for our society
personally I think they're already just
as dangerous as the government I mean
they're already Facebook and Google and
Apple are already colluding with the
government in some aspects but honestly
I think that there is private
corporations will never be more
dangerous than the government and like I
said unless they start colluding with it
so I don't see this because we the
consumers still have some of the power
you know it's like you know everyone
going from MySpace onto Facebook
everyone was concerned about this when
it came to myspace but what happened
something I guess slight
better came along and we and we all
jumped ship speaking with the privilege
and confidence of a white Christian man
speaking of white Christians white white
Christians now comprise only 43% of the
population for the first time ever a
minority according to the Public
Religion Research Institute four decades
ago that number was over 80 percent this
is a huge decline Amanda and I are
obviously a little swarthy probably to
count and roaming is slightly Asiatic
but Jacob you are now a minority should
you be entitled to affirmative action
protections oh absolutely
no I'm just kidding but for my
perspective as a as a Christian I'm not
too too concerned with this to me it
seemed more like it's a label thing so
people aren't wanting to label
themselves as mainline Protestants or
evangelicals I certainly don't want to
label myself either and we're seeing
that kind of go away that labeling
system now as far as is white
Christianity and decline who cares as
long as as me as a Christian as long as
long as white people are in it no I'm
for me it's more about spreading the
faith as a Christian I'm more concerned
so if more people are coming to Christ
who are not white what what do I care to
me it's all about them coming into the
faith it's all about the Jesus roaming
will this new minority status for white
Christians finally throw a wrench into
these stupid intersectional hierarchies
of victimhood that we've been hearing
from the left forever and ever or do
their feelings not care about facts well
yeah that's an interesting question I've
thought about that myself a couple times
too and you know I don't think it's
gonna change anything because if we look
at who the left is signs victimhood
status to start really anyone who's
necessarily a minority or objectively
oppressed it's anyone who goes against
the Christian Right right and even when
it doesn't make sense like Islam right
they're not they're not a minority on
the planet
you know they've for the longest time
throughout history not been oppress or
rather the oppressors and yet for some
reason they still get victim status so
you know that's an instance of where
it's not really about whose action
oppressed or who's being marginalized
it's just anyone to give the middle
finger to the Christian right right so
even if the Christian right eventually
becomes themselves a minority that
doesn't mean that regressives are gonna
be our friend through that the left will
all of a sudden start speaking up for
our civil liberties now that's that's
never gonna happen and the smallest
minority is the individual and the left
can't stand to the individual for the
most Amanda this is a major demographic
and ideological shift what are the
hazards or potential benefits that it
presents in American culture because it
is a big change
yeah I mean we've seen secularism grow
and then as people get more secular they
look to something to kind of fill that
void and they look to big government so
I think as we're seeing lasts not a sin
just Christianity but but you know they
like a monotheistic religion as there's
an absence of that people are looking
for something to fill that void and you
know that's why we're kind of we're
seeing a push towards socialism our
health care is you know right about to
be there so so I think that's one of the
big repercussions that is just
inevitable when you have a growing
increase of secularism leave it to
Amanda presto Giacomo to cheer everybody
after and okay panel it has been
wonderful to have you as always roaming
millennial Amanda presto Giacomo and
Jacob Barry that's our whole show for
today the whole shows about Ben Shapiro
and I'm not gonna go give a final
thought about Ben Shapiro so make sure
you get your mailbag questions in we
will be doing the mailbag tomorrow so
send them all and if you're a subscriber
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show come back tomorrow we'll do it
all again
[Music]
[Music]